I’m thinking about getting a new phone.
Should I get the one that’s dull and lifeless
or clean and shiny?
Oooh… shiny…
Hey there glossy gatherers, Jules here for
Dnews!
From a very early age, we as humans are intrinsically
attracted to shiny things.
Lip gloss, mirror-finish car paints, diamonds,
even glossy paper!
That might seem obvious to say, the same behavior
doesn’t seem to be universal throughout
the animal kingdom.
We used to think magpies were attracted to
shiny things, but a 2014 study disproved that
idea, and found that they were actually afraid
of them, as well as any new objects in general.
In fact, our research had trouble finding
any other animals with a marked predisposition
to shiny objects in the same way humans seem
to be practically obsessed with them.
Plenty of theories have been proposed.
Some believe it’s just an aesthetic preference
that’s picked up as you age.
Your parents like shiny things, so you like
shiny things.
But a study in Ecological Psychology from
2010 observed infants and toddlers being drawn
to shiny mirrors, and even licking their surface
as if lapping at a pool of liquid, so the
attraction appears innate.
In fact, this response in babies is telling.
Could it be that shiny things just remind
us of water?
In 2014, researchers from Ghent University
and the University of Houston conducted six
different studies to try and narrow down humanity’s
attraction to shininess.
The first two-part study asked children around
the age of five and full-grown adults to rank
glossy and non-glossy paper to their preference.
This was in order to a) establish that adults
do like shiny things, and b) to establish
that children like them too, before being
socialized to the idea.
The researchers hypothesized that we are drawn
to gloss because our brains associate it with
water, and to test that hypothesis, they gave
a new set of participants glossy and matte
pictures of both aquatic landscapes and deserts.
They found that people did indeed believe
the aquatic images were glossier than the
desert images, despite the photo having the
same level of gloss or matte.
And just in case, to rule out the hypothesis
that maybe we like glossy things simply because
they’re just visually appealing, like the
way symmetry is, the researchers conducted
another study.
They blindfolded the participants and had
them touch rough matte and smooth glossy paper,
and then had them rate quality and attractiveness
of the material.
The participants rated the glossy paper higher,
despite not even seeing it.
The final experiment was examining if the
feeling of thirst, and craving water, could
also elicit a reaction to glossy materials.
They fed participants salty crackers, and
had them evaluate their preference for either
matte or glossy pictures.
Tellingly, the thirsty group was drawn more
to shininess, showing a potential correlation,
and thus a potential conclusion.
So, do we like shiny things just because they
remind us of water?
Well, maybe.
This is just six studies coming from the same
researchers, so it may be a lot more complicated
than just reminding us of water.
We don’t know yet.
More research is definitely needed.
We can’t do DNews episodes without support
from our sponsors.
Special thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring
this episode.
For 100 years, every kiss begins with Kay.
If our attraction to shiny things is because
we associate it with water...what happens
to our body when we can’t find water?
Check out this video about dehydration, here.
What about you?
What’s your favorite shiny thing?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe to DNews
for more videos every day.